the kind of aha moment was when I was
working with clients around trying to
take in direct short positions on the
student loan market and I was like wow
if really smart people are betting
against the student loan market then
that that brings huge negative
consequences for in that
first-generation an eighteen year old
student who's navigating the biggest
financial decision of their lives
completely by themselves I'm Kelly
peeler I'm 29 years old and I'm the
founder and CEO of next-gen best at
next-gen best we help Gen Z navigate and
manage the student loan process all over
text message we send students emojis and
gifts to really build trust with them we
help them optimize or lower their
student loan principal payments and then
actually help them in college and
throughout college come up with a plan
so that they had chances of lowering
their student loan payments
[Music]
after studying the history of financial
crises in college I went to go work in
the financial crisis during 2008 on Wall
Street at JPMorgan and that's really
where I got my hands dirty understanding
the dynamics around the student loan
market and how predatory this whole
process was for the 70 million people
who will be entering the financial
system for the first time
[Music]
I think the most important trait for
being an entrepreneur is just having the
absolute unrelenting willingness to
continue to get to a solution and to
iterate and to actually adjust and to
not take no for an answer
I'm a huge believer as a student of
financial history that the next
financial crisis is rooted in the
student loan market we see ourselves as
preventing that
so both providing transparency an actual
plan and actually putting students on
the right pathway so that they know what
they're getting themselves into and can
actually respond to it and change their
decisions whether it's major whether
it's where they live so that they
actually know the right information
moving forward
I personally define success if I am
inspired every day if I'm working on
important problems and if I'm actually
helping people and I feel like I'm
making forward momentum and changing
their lives
you